let's talk about some of the guys that
are destined to go in round one let's
start with kyler murray
what what do you see i think we both
agree his ceiling is number one yep
what's the lowest you think he could be
drafted four i think it's you know i
think number four to the oakland raiders
i i think if he is on the board there at
four
that that would be the one guy the
raiders would take uh
at that position that's just me i don't
know that for sure i just know john
gruden's you know love that he has for
these type of quarterbacks that would
make me think that's true but uh gosh if
arizona doesn't take him at number one
this is gonna be i mean you know we're
gonna i think see some action in the
front top top four where there's gonna
be some big time trades i gotta think
there's somebody else out there that
thinks kyla murray is very special is
gonna try to get up and get him uh you
know somewhere at pick two three or four
and that's my next question for you
because if we frame out his floor and
ceiling as four to the raiders and one
to the cardinals at number two and john
lynch the gm of the 49ers spoke about it
this week at his pre-draft press
conference he expects the phone to ring
if kyle murray is there at number two
who are the teams you think would be
most likely to try to get to number two
or number three to snag kyler murray
before john gruden came yeah i mean
that's that's the million-dollar
question and then you know that's the
one thing that i've heard very little
about the first team that really comes
to my mind is john guerin's brother and
jay gruden and the washington redskins
you know again just being around the
grunin family i just think they fancy
these type of quarterbacks these guys
that of course can run and make plays on
their own and you know get you know what
i would call have a get out of jail free
card when maybe the pass play that was
called nobody's open oh well okay kyle
murray run around and make 10 yards with
your legs that's why we drafted you
that's what he can do for an offense so
certainly he jumps to mind you know i
don't think that the miami dolphins as
much as they're they need a quarterback
i don't think that would be brian flores
chad o'shea these are new england guys
type of quarterback that they would want
to run their system so
mike i don't have any concrete answers
for you there i really think when i look
at that i go oakland washington those
would be the two teams i look at the
most maybe an outside chance of the new
york giants but again i don't think kyle
murray would be the type of guy that the
giants brass gettleman the maras tisch
uh i think they like you know kind of
the traditional pocket passing type
quarterback to where i'd be shocked
there as well so it's another great
question and i don't have a great answer
for you i'm sorry well and the giants
are one of the teams he did visit he
visited the cardinals and the giants
worked out for the raiders worked out
for the cardinals so the giants are a
team to keep an eye on but there were
reports early on once he picked football
over baseball that the giants literally
prefer a giant not a little guy at
quarterbacks all right the next guy i
want to talk about at the quarterback
position drew lock you have a very high
opinion of him you think the giants
should take him with the sixth overall
pick what do you see drew locke's window
being high and low yeah i i think really
it's really six to 32. i think that
would be like so that whole window there
you know again the miami dolphins would
they certainly on the radar i think to a
drew lock would be to their liking uh i
think that other than kyla murray if you
made me bet who washington redskins have
as their number two quarterback i would
bet you it's drew locke again because of
his athletic ability i think he would uh
they would jay gruden would fancy a drew
lock over at dwayne haskins and then at
the very least i think if he's on the
board at number 32
new england patriots are going to sprint
to the podium and draft drew locke i
think that again he would be the kind of
guy that they would like as well and
realize wow we could pass the torch off
from brady to drew lock you know we
might not miss a beat as an organization
if we have that guy at quarterback
you know i got him going at number 10 to
the denver broncos and the more you talk
about it the more i like it here's the
thing yeah
john elway has spent the last eight
years looking for another john elway and
there may never be another john elway at
least not in his lifetime but he fits
that mold right a guy who's too good for
the team he was on a guy whose team had
a bad record now it didn't keep elway
from being the first overall pick but it
affected drew locke this year but a guy
that's got the skill set the athletic
ability a guy who can be groomed and
molded and maybe could be a a junior
version of a john elway and elway i
think feeling that urgency to find a guy
who's going to be the quarterback for
years to come joe flacco clearly a
short-term band-aid type of solution and
when when flacco's making 18 million
this year and drew lock would be under a
rookie weight scale contract you can
afford in the budget the money that it
would take to have both guys on the
roster you're still going to be paying
far less than the teams that are paying
guys at the top of the market that's
right and and i won't be mad at john
elway if he did take drew lock at 10. i
get it i understand it there is there's
some comparisons there
i mean i'm not gonna say he's john elway
but his arm is special uh and he's an
athlete who can really throw in some
awkward positions just like john elway
could you know he can scramble out to
the right and throw a 50-yard laser all
the way across the field to the left for
a completion and put it on the money
that's john elway type stuff so drew
lock certainly capable of that and mike
you brought up a great point about the
team thing too i just hate that crap i
really do you know too much time the
quarterback gets lumped in with the team
damn i mean again i'll say it again gino
toretta should have been the number one
pick then i mean he won the heisman and
miami was unbeatable when he was there
oh that's right you know he wasn't that
great whatever it may be i mean patrick
mahomes and texas tech went five and
seven you know yeah john elway went
three and seven tell me how that worked
out when they got to the nfl team
matters and drew lock had a crappy
offense and some not so
great coaches i'll say this past year on
the offensive side of the ball you go
back and watch his junior year and the
years before that you see a little bit
more of a polished different player and
i think that goes into the coaching so
you know i just don't always agree with
how people uh you know kind of lump that
together
all right let's move on to dwayne
haskins the guy that i firmly believe
would be in in the conversation for the
top overall pick but for kyler murray
he's a guy who had a great season 50
touchdown passes excellent performance
in the rose bowl a guy who gets knocked
unfairly for lack of mobility we've
watched the film we've talked about it
the guy can move when he needs to and he
can keep plays alive behind the line of
scrimmage which is critical in this day
and age as teams devote more resources
to their front seven and to their attack
on an opposing quarterback so what do
you see the high and the low being for
former ohio state quarterback dwayne
haskins i see the high as being number
six of the new york giants i don't
believe that the the oakland raiders
would take dwayne haskins i don't see
that as being a john gruden type of
quarterback i really don't why not you
know why not because he doesn't believe
in the big pocket pastor he didn't want
me i mean i know that i mean rich mckay
drafted me i i don't you know he wants
the guy that was a little smaller and
maybe a little bit more of a runner uh
that way to where yeah i don't know if
the tom brady's and the peyton mannings
are his cup of tea that kind of way
that's just not what he's about he loved
alex smith and that kind of play when he
was coming out i remember it going damn
he's drooling all over this guy because
he can just scramble a little but it
doesn't look like he can throw the ball
down the field all that well so yeah i
look at four at six as being the high
point and i go all the way down to 32
for dwayne haskins too you know i'm very
if he was on the board at 32 that would
be interesting he fits the mold of what
new england likes here's another aspect
for new england just to throw that out
there with dwayne haskins they did have
greg chiano who was there at ohio state
so they're going to know everything
about dwayne haskins and whether they
loved him but i doubt that he lasts that
long on the board
when did you first know that gruden
didn't want you
uh
good question
people
uh i could tell first of all that he had
never really watched me because after
the first two days of otas i made some
throws and some plays and you've heard
john lynch refer to it a little bit
before where i think i opened up eyes
even with him and everybody else and he
called me in the office after like two
practices and he was watching my texas
film and he was watching some of my
throws going damn how'd you make this
throw whoa why'd you do this what'd you
see here to launch this one blah blah
blah and i remember sitting there going
man he never watched me play this is the
first time
and i slowly had people in the
organization start telling me that rich
mckay was the one who drafted me so
that's how i kind of found out
all right one more before we take our
break daniel jones we look they've been
leading us to believe they pretty much
everybody that that he is the giant's
pick yeah the question is where do the
giants pick him what do you see his
framework being of when the giants would
pick him high when the giants would pick
him low i know i don't mean to be boring
but again i think his window is six to
32 too because i just look at it and go
okay if the giants don't take him at six
then i'm not so sure they really want
him at 17 either i mean if he's your guy
he's your guy you got to take him i'd be
scared if i was the giants at six that
maybe a team like maybe the miami
dolphins they could fancy a guy like a
daniel jones because they want somebody
that can you know orchestrate that new
england josh mcdaniel's offense so i
think it's six to 32. uh another guy
that i think if he's on the board he
would fit the new england mold i can
understand them wanting him uh but
somewhere in that range i think if the
giants are sold on him and i really
believe that uh and i've documented
those reasons why uh i think you gotta
take him at six and not roll the dice on
17.
do any of these guys that we've talked
about just now kyler murray drew locked
wayne haskins daniel jones do any of
them fall out obviously kyle murray
won't but they're the guys you're saying
their floor is 32 could their flow floor
be lower than 32 could they fall out of
round one altogether i would really be
shocked especially with the what i call
the big three i mean when i go murray
you know lock haskins i look at those
three i would just be absolutely shocked
if they fell out of the first round i
really would be daniel jones he'd be the
one where i'd go oh i wouldn't expect
that but you know i don't think his
talent is a first round talent so uh i
wouldn't be as surprised as the other
guys
[Music]
give me the guy most likely to be
quarterback number five taken into the
first round and you're assessing oh if
it i you know it that to be would be a
two-man race between jared stidham from
auburn and ryan finley from north
carolina state you know i think it would
probably be more likely to be stidhum
who was a guy that was being talked
about as a first-round pick after two
years ago when auburn was good but again
you know what happened auburn was crappy
this year and everybody blames jared
sidham for that i mean because that
there's nobody else out there it's just
a quarterback he's doing it all i mean
it didn't matter that the guy couldn't
get protected they couldn't get a
receiver open you know they had a grade
school pass offense that didn't matter
so uh i i am a big fan of sidom i think
he is a guy that's got got some
potential reminds me of tony romo
i'm not giving up on my guy will grow oh
i know you're not round one his high low
his high low is bottom around one into
round three and i hope minnesota takes
us
well
you know you brought that topic up at a
time where there's really nothing else i
can say because we have to take a break
but uh i guess i wouldn't complain about
that if that were to happen
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports